hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video you know
it's coming up on the year end I think
believe tomorrow is the last trading day
of the year uh December 30th and you
know I was watching uh someone's video
that they had posted on order flow and I
got a little
triggered again you know trigger alert
and you know the person you know
although their style of trading deals
with uh stacked imbalances okay fair
enough I mean you know there's many ways
to use order flow and you know stacked
imbalances is one of the ways you know I
use stacked imbalances but there's water
flow is so robust there's so many
different things that you could look at
in the order flow but what really what
triggered me is is they they made a
comment that order flow uh isn't useful
in commodity markets you know it's only
uh really applicable to the stock the
stock indices which is complete utter
nonsense right there's so many
successful order flow traders that trade
just Commodities right they trade the
grains uh they trade obviously the
metals and crude oil
they don't even touch the equity markets
and you know yeah you know Equity
markets they sound you know cool sexy I
trade the S PS you know it sounds much
more uh professional than saying you
know I'm a weak Trader I'm a corn Trader
or you know I'm a copper Trader you know
people say hey we can trade corn you
trade wheat but you know what the same
principles that apply in analyzing the
order flow in the equity markets apply
to the commodity markets you know
honestly up until the uh stock indices
you know really started taking off in
the
um I mean I think they're introduced in
the 80s but you know the e-minis didn't
come around to the late 90s you know
more millionaires were made in the
soybean pit than any other trading pit
out there and you know I just want to
talk about looking at Commodities you
know relative to uh some of the you know
the stock indices now this is a e-mini
this is just a one minute chart this is
from today December uh 29th and you know
this green line is up here at the high
and you know we started coming off from
that high okay and when you're looking
at the order flows do I like using order
flows because you know it just makes
understanding what's happening at a high
of the day easier to trade okay because
again not every single high is going to
be as easy as this one
but we're coming up into the high you
get some nice positive Delta readings
okay point of controls are going up
Delta's 144 316 646 then you start to go
sideways
as you're going sideways you got
negative Delta but it's kind of small
negative Delta minus 16 minus 38 minus
50 minus 43 you know minus 223 minus 600
and you got a nice big stack selling and
balance sticking in right there right
off the high of the day and you know the
market proceeds to sell off from about
the 68 area down into the 62s you know
within about 10 minutes right that was a
nice uh easy trade to take if you're
looking at the e-minis today you know
eventually we did sort of come back and
take out those new highs you know if
you're watching the imbalances right the
Stacked and balances you had one here
you had one coming in here you know
right as this move is starting to kick
off uh you know later in this in the
session going in near the close again
you know very nice uh Delta reading if
you know you're watching it going into
the close today you're sort of going
sideways then you see the Deltas really
start to pick up here minus 116 minus
271 minus 900 Stacks selling a balance
and the market
um again sells off from around the
74-ish area you know down into this you
know literally down to 70.
um you know then that's when the cash
closed so
you know what when I hear oh you know
you can only use order flow on the stock
markets you know the stock indices the
e-minis
ETC and not the Commodities let's you
know that really bothers me because
when I first started using order flow I
traded Commodities right I traded uh
wheat the soybeans palm oil right palm
oil is traded in Malaysia it's because I
was working in Asia right that that's
you know how I know about those markets
and how I know that order flow Works in
it so let's take a look at uh soybeans
here real quick uh Zs is the symbol
for the Chicago Board of Trade soybeans
and we'll just pull up the chart here
come on ninjatrader there we go
uh we'll just go back you know to today
right this is one minute chart same
chart that I'm looking at on the e-minis
okay so Market opens up at 8 30 I mean
it trades overnight but you know the
main session starts at 8 30 and we're
going up what do we get as we're going
up you know a nice stack buying a
balance going up I'm going to control is
sort of moving higher you get up here to
this highest level right up here and
things start changing you'll notice as
we're coming up into this high it's
getting a little bit weak right you got
negative Delta just off the high and
then big strong burst to bind big strong
positive Delta uh 559 then negative
small positive strong negative we're
still at our high and after that big
burst of buying
no basically no continuation we just see
seven negative Delta 77 and then small
positive 27 big negative minus 187
hit the high again very small Delta of
four
take into a new high and it's a red
candle with positive Delta people say
okay you got positive Delta at the high
but what you have is a Delta and bar
Divergence so you're at the high of the
day positive Delta okay that should be
encouraging but why is the market
closing down because I see Supply coming
in here you see this volume the 177.
which tells me that you know there's
people willing to sell it up here at
this high and then you go small Delta 10
and then big negative Delta minus 110
minus 61 minus 57.
so we're up here at the high and
majority of the Delta after that big
burst is negative
okay what do you make of that you're at
the high of the day you're seeing
selling coming in not only are you
seeing you know the aggressive selling
showing up in the negative deltas
what you're seeing Supply coming in in
the form of strong passive right
liquidity in the market liquidity is
being added into the market people are
working limit orders up here at you know
1524 they're absorbing whatever buying
is still you know buyers are still
coming in to to trade
and Market is reacting to that
okay come back up here sort of test that
high back up here to 24 right we had
that 177 here
remember now that was at 1524 Market
sells off down to 19 and a quarter
rallies back up where to where that you
had that Supply you can see the point
control right on the edge of the bar you
see the volume 142.
what happens Market reacts to that
goes sideways eventually starts selling
off and even on this move down you know
you're seeing
you know get more Supply coming into the
market here and you just see you know
nice selling on this move down
right now I I get why the person was
saying you know Commodities don't really
follow order flow that well is because
they base you know their whole strategy
you know the the software that they sell
is a system based on looking for stacked
um imbalances right stack buying a
balance stack selling vouchers which is
fine but you in Commodities in certain
Commodities like soybeans is a little
bit more volatile but it does have a
nice volume but if you're looking at
um you know another market like soy like
Wheats okay this is soybeans but if
you're looking at another commodity uh
such as wheat yeah you're just not going
to get that many imbalances stacked
imbalances
in the wheat Market just because you
know it's you're going to see imbalances
but they're going to be sort of spread
out they're not going to be stacked
neatly on each other the way that you'd
see them in other markets and that's the
wrong symbol let me just pull it up here
this is pulling up the stock so I don't
have stock quotes but um basically
you're not going to get it because the
volume is just not there to give you
those stacked imbalances so this is
again this is wheat today right you
don't see many stacked imbalances
there's one here one there
um you know one here
one here
one here here okay so I mean and that's
about it right you get a lot of times in
commodity markets where it's just moving
like this
and if you're just looking at stacked
imbalances you know that limits you on
what you could look at you know you'd
have to change basically the type of
chart you're looking at you know you
probably couldn't use a minute based
chart you'd probably want to use a
arranged base chart okay just to give
you a little bit more movement
so again you know to say Commodities you
can't use order flow and commodities is
just nonsense right there's so many
Traders out there using order flow on
Commodities that's all they look at this
is gold let's go to a one minute chart
here you know Gold's a great Market you
know I'll talk about copper in a second
copper you know is one of these
underrated markets but you know same
sort of things you look at this right
come up this is today come up to the
high you got this nice reversal at the
High
you hit the high what do you got
negative Delta okay so you got a
Divergence not only that you got that
imbalance that buying imbalance I know
there's Supply coming in here uh to help
push this Market back down I sort of see
a sweep taking place with all this lack
of counter trade here
um you'll see the five the zero zeros
and the nine so it's telling me someone
just came in and whacked it down through
about you know from basically
2680 down to you know 26.50 so about you
know three ticks
you got nice stacks on a balance there
and the market just drops off okay it's
the same sort of analysis that I'm doing
whether it's e-minis or
uh soybeans or or gold right let's take
a look at some of these other highs
right going into the highs nice you know
aggressive buying stack buying
imbalances there that's what you like to
see
um you come up here these guys are kind
of Trapped we don't go build off of it
but you know you'd be looking at the
same things right it's not like you're
looking at different things but you do
have to realize depending on the market
that you're trading if you're just
focused on one piece of the order flow
yeah it might not be effective in
certain markets you know for example
let's take a look at
um
you know take a look at gosh hu I think
that's uh Hogs
um
nothing exciting about trading the hog
market but you know you're still going
to be essentially looking for the same
thing so here's a market right this is a
one minute chart very thin volumes so
yeah trading order flow is probably not
going to be very effective if you're
looking at stacked imbalances but if
you're looking at other things like the
Delta honestly on a one minute chart
there's not much to go off of you might
want to bump it up to a five minute
chart or a range based chart
but there's going to be times in every
Market where there is a decent volume
being traded and you know really what
you want to be looking at is you know
how is the market reacting you know
around the lows is there signs of
aggressive buying and this is why I like
Commodities more than equities
is because you know really the the
traders that are trading you know some
of these markets they're there for a
reason right they have to trade it right
they they either need to take delivery
or they have the supply that they've got
to move so you know personally I find it
it holds order flow you know much more
truer than say you know some of these
markets just have you know people are
parking their money there then they got
to take it out to put it into another
investment that's what s PS are for
right people get out of one market they
need to park the money so they park it
in s PS they don't park it in in markets
like you know Hogs or Copperas take a
look at Copper I like copper
um HG
but you know if you're really had to
trade this Market with order flow you
can
um you know that market meaning
um
Hogs or certain things and Hogs that I
like to look for I don't really I don't
trade Hogs but you know sometimes people
ask me about it and I take a look and I
say yeah you know you should key and is
this and that so this is copper okay
um let's just go back
today
and look for some interesting things
here so you know there's always
interesting things in the order flow so
this line is the open price 380 350.
okay and I think today was kind of a
quiet day but you know what you'd be
looking for is you know signs in the
Delta that aggressive trading is picking
up or cooling off
most of the time you're seeing some
small Deltas small volumes
overall here it's kind of a quiet day
but there's going to be times where
things really start to pick up okay and
you can sort of see it in here you're
starting to see some stronger Delta some
heavier volumes come in
um you know just sort of looking at this
as it's going sideways
you know you've seen some decent
negative Deltas minus 13 minus 19. okay
that just goes back to -6 which is
nothing 14 okay minus 9 then 0 5 3 then
minus 27 minus 66 so their selling is
picking up here okay then it doesn't
make much of a move it just sort of goes
sideways eventually sort of works its
way back up but as it's working its way
back up you see the Deltas now starting
to pick up 53 41 98 the aggressive
buying is coming in looking at the delta
divided by volume right there's some
strong numbers 41 46. so you know that
the the aggressive trading is really
starting to pick up here right sort of
gave you this false sense of security
that maybe this Market's going to sell
off okay that's fine you know you get
short
maybe in here somewhere but just sort of
hangs around here doesn't go anywhere
right but as a Trader you have to be
able to recognize when the Market's not
really moving you're starting to see
some signs here with the Delta divided
by volume you know picking up some nice
um strong ratio numbers that's why it's
colored blue
but again even if you're not convinced
by that some people go how the hell am I
supposed to trade This And Trades is
basically the bid and the offer
and you know one tick above one tick
below but by the time it gets over here
and you see the volumes start to pick up
this Bar's got 600 contracts traded and
Then followed by 99 followed by 200
maybe now you're a little bit more
convinced you know as opposed to here
which is trading 20 contracts that this
Market can go higher and it starts
working its way back up you know from
the 380 270 you know all the way up to
383.
um 30.
okay so again you know don't
fall into this thing that you know order
flow is only effective on
um
stock indices you know bonds Ultra bonds
great contracts for trade 10 years
technically not Commodities obviously
they're not stocks but you know those
are markets that trade decent size you
know during the trading day
where you know there's a lot of volume
right this is a one minute chart but
honestly I like to look at uh five range
charts or four range charts in the
interest rates
makes it just a little bit easier for me
to understand you know when it's sort of
taking into account
what's happening in terms of price
movement and again if you're looking at
stacked imbalances you're not going to
get very many
right there's imbalances taking place
but they're kind of spread out
whereas if you're looking at you know
um an e-mini chart which go back to the
minis real quick you're going to get a
lot more imbalances just based off the
nature of the market so again you know
order flow is very robust there's so
many things you could look at you can
look at
obviously imbalances stacked imbalances
you could look at multiple imbalances
you can look at point of controls you
know how where the point of controls lie
in the bar
um you know you'll get Delta how's Delta
you know it's just easier sometimes in
markets that trade a lot of volume
you get more of a grip on it then you
know markets that don't trade a lot of
volume but that it's just nonsense to
say order flow isn't applicable to
commodity markets it's just nonsense so
anyway guys you know I hope you
appreciate this video you know it's kind
of a gripe of mine
um
of how when people say your order flow
doesn't apply to commodity markets when
actually I find
commodity markets much easier to trade
than
the stock markets so but that's just me
all right everyone we've all got our
opinions we're all entitled to our
opinions so throw stones at me whatever
be sure to like And subscribe the
channel so we can continue making these
videos for you so anyway guys have a
great day and I'll catch you guys on the
next video bye-bye